coming out in February and so we've got
you know mark Tara and the team are
doing an incredible job finishing it up
it's almost done and yeah we're super
happy to be here and be able to show a
little bit more of the game tonight so
what are we gonna see tonight from the
game well so a lot of what we've shown
so far is the gameplay it's super fun
you're basically you know an armored
superhero in a fantasy setting and we've
shown a lot of that we haven't really
let people in on what the story is and
the characters and things like that but
you know like a great Bioware a game
we're building out a whole world of
story and things for you to discover and
characters to me so we're gonna start
letting you in on a little bit more of
that I know the entire team is working
very hard on this right yeah I mean
we've got a big team working on it but
we've got a few projects at Bioware so
it's not the only thing that we're
working on and so we do have a few
surprises left okay but anthem right now
anthem right now and always thinking
about our next thing all right
I tried all right here's a look at
anthem check it out
I have seen the power of the anthem
destroy entire civilizations you have no
idea what the heart of rageful do that
person I feel a new power it's calling
me the generations our people struggle
just to survive and again the javelins
allowed us to fight back the chaos on
the walls protected our families
loved ones remember we're a team I'm
right there with you as a freelancer job
always has been but still rages
and walls can only do so much
but with the power of the anthem
tips
all this needless suffering
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the game